I'm optimistic because i think the
global community is moving in the right
direction you know the the concerts that
took place prior to Nelson Mandela's
release with people people like Peter
Gabriel the songs like Steve Biko that
saw Mandela's release that brought about
the end of apartheid and you know that
those great concerts were you know what
were and you know we're a sign of the
times I think like a wonderful concerts
that are taking place on the global
warming and concerts that's a sign of
the times it shows that you know the
people of now wanting that their voices
to be heard and governments you could
have to listen
you